hello
it's pleasure to be here today i'm
talking about apple breeding calmly
propagated crops and their complexity
um
it is
interesting to work with a very diverse
crop
one that
is a hybrid of two
different genetic systems the cyan and
the root stock
and to appreciate how much diversity
there is and how much can be harnessed
for genetic improvement
so you're going to hear from a bunch of
us about genes technologies new
varieties but what i'd like to do is
discuss preparing yourself for a career
in plant breeding by following what has
set some of us
many of us apart
and realizing that everything is complex
even stuff that we thought was very
simple we have learned is incredibly
complex
and as a researcher you need to figure
out how you're going to look at the
micro and macro views of this complexity
second is that you really need to become
an expert in your field
and that means by always reading new
research old research forming
collaborations and making use of others
expertise
people are incredibly generous and are
willing to help just have to ask
and by trusting your gut my advisor
for my master's degree always talked
about serendipity and he called it being
in the right place at the right time
with the right set of eyes
and trusting your gut means that you
read or see that citation for a paper
four times and then say well maybe i
better read that um
[Music]
there's all sorts of opportunities
out there and sometimes the best failure
can
um
seem awful at the time but lead you to
new discoveries
so some fast facts on apple there's um
now
probably over 60 000 genes that have
been discovered we have genomic
sequences from alice domestica a haploid
accession
doubletaploid accession we have 17
chromosomes we have many areas of
genetic duplication
apple has been around forever and has
evolved during those times we have many
transposable elements
or jumping genes that can activate and
deactivate genes and then you
these are best known for color sports
and architecture but then you have
transcription factors that are also
complicating things and methylation
we have 25 to 34 different malic species
and sadly only a few of them have really
been
leveraged
we have tremendous genetic and
phenotypic diversity apple is wild in
that extent we have self-incompatibility
and inbreeding depression that enforces
reinforces that heterozygosity
and we're clonally propagated that's a
strength because we can fix something
but it's a challenge because there are
many viruses that can be difficult to
detect and once detected can make
commercial commercialization a nightmare
we're also marketed by name which gives
you the ability to
really capitalize on development of the
brand
so you can see
the amazing amount of syntony
the activity of transposable elements
the
methyl methylation that occurs in apple
so what this means is if you find
something a qtl on chromosome 2 you
better also look at chromosome 7 and
chromosome 15 because there are areas of
duplication
so i love transposons somebody else's
twitter account is iheart transposons
but um
this is we have a competition in the lab
to find the most in the field um this
isn't mine so i'm i'm in the second
running but a lot of different
activation of different colors
this russeted chimera was used by one of
my graduate students to be able to
determine that
russeting enhanced the production of
fluoridation
this is an apple that every fruit is
chimeric
gala is similar to that
seedling chimera spur habits also
imposed by a chimera and columnar growth
habit which we feel will have amazing
potential for robotics is also
uh conferred
by activity of transposons
but as again i say nothing is easy we
always used to think that the genetics
of
apple color were pretty straightforward
what these diagrams are showing you is
four different color sports of the same
variety it could be delicious or fuji
and you can see the tremendous
difference between these what we call
simple genetic mutations
there's you know hundreds of genes that
are differentially expressed and there's
transcription factors and there's
activation by uv light by cold
temperature by stress
and so this is where i was saying
understand that
complexity is complexity excuse me
understanding variation so we have we
know that there's differences depending
on crop load
king dominance or the fact that the king
flower is usually the strongest as is
the fruit
and how you sample whether you choose a
king or a lateral
will influence the type of data that you
obtained so you have to be very careful
what's the age of the tree the root
stock the season the spray is used the
stage of maturity
a failure to account for some of these
will can ruin your experiments
developmental stages are also important
ethylene is a major contributor to apple
ripening and also influences other
traits so understand that become best
friends with your physiologist or post
harvest physiologist pathologist
entomologist
so we know that studies
are
greatly influenced by the maturity of
the fruit that you're testing and
when i first started i realized that the
previous breeders were using very ripe
fruit as their indice for quality
whereas the growers are picking at this
stage
so in numerous genomic and genetic
studies that we've done i've always
stressed that we need to have a stage we
can characterize we can use ethylene
that would be great if we could use a d
a
meter because by using overripe fruit
a lot of what you hope to learn or to
change
it's already too late
so we breed for quality of course but
also nutrition
we are fortunate that our program has
great latitude to study
different things
and i remember my own children's toddler
stages which could be incredibly
frustrating but are also helpful for us
because we need to be like them and and
to never lose that
questioning of why why does that happen
how does that happen what is it
and reading the literature will help
it's a key to all our success and we've
leveraged that knowledge to make
advances for example our nutrition
research benefited from a very
little published or expanded 1962 study
climate change breeding will be a
challenge that we all have to look at
and
move forward with
so this is the diversity we see just for
um
[Music]
leaf morphology so normal apple leaf
looks like the smaller
leaf on the stone but we have some that
look like rosemary leaves and you can
see that the leaves are actually growing
on the trunk which we've never seen to
that extent before leaf loping
can appear in one progeny and
have very little expression but be
in the
background of other progenies
we were able to
amp up the expression of red leaf color
and
these make wonderful summer scholars or
graduate student studies for flowers you
saw the
initial
single blossoms but this is the kind of
variation we can have in terms of color
number of blossoms
vibrancy
a lot of double flowers and we had a
summer scholar that determined that
some
[Music]
genotypes that are homozygous for double
flowers are in fact lethals
tree form again what's not to love about
this so you have trees that have the
kilometer habit
are segregating for dwarfs are
shaped like a wheel without pruning
uh weeping
we want branch angles that are about 90
degrees for greatest strength and this
is just a snapshot of some of the
diversity
and then
i talk about complexity never have two
guys name ben in your lab because it
makes life very interesting but ben
archesky
is someone that looked at elvis
prunifolia and looked at something i was
really intrigued about which was pale
green lethal a lot of breeders said we
don't see pale green lethal
i saw a lot of our progenies 25 of the
population would die due to this
lethality
and ben uh took it on as a side project
and did such a good job with it it
became a nefa-funded
doctoral
scholarship for him
we made the connection that vitamin k
was involved in pilgrim lethality
and i had googled a colleague that
contacted me and found out that he was
an expert in phylloquinone again
serendipity perhaps being prepared
perhaps but he was able to
provide us with the means to assay for
vitamin k and very small catalytions
don archevsky offered the other ben ben
gutierrez the leftover malice printfolia
seeds because it seemed that they were
segregating for traits that ben thought
was of interest
so ben gutierrez surveyed the usda apple
collection at geneva he looked at
segregation of fluoridazine dihydro
chalcones fluoridazine trilobitin and
cybolden which are important in glucose
metabolism but also
in their role as bitter blockers and
sweeteners
he conducted
gbs
she
sorry gps
on this progeny
and uh this progeny is segregating for
all sorts of amazing things um he
convinced me to to plant several more of
those progenies
and we'll continue to look at this role
ben is now the curator of the apple
journalism collection so this
collaboration will be long-lived
switch a little bit because i'm talking
a lot about a lot of different things
but what's intriguing about this is as a
breeder as a geneticist seeing your
varieties in the supermarket is
absolutely priceless
having someone right to tell you that
it's their favorite apple it's
absolutely um amazing
and these were two apples that we did
under a club system where only certain
growers but in this case all growers in
new york state had the option to apply
the last three varieties that we have
released are open releases so that
anyone
has the opportunity to enjoy them
so in the future look for a fully
russeted apple
it's one of the most amazing tasting
apples that i've had the um
the good fortune to try and to develop
um
and then this is an example of some of
the output from our
ornamental breeding which is columnar
and double flower that's my technician
kevin maloney who is
a wonderful resource to the program
so challenges we're going to have
invasives every program is going to have
invasives how devastating they are and
what we can do about them
will require
collaboration with entomologists but we
have
brown spar
brown
marmorated stink bug ambrosia beetle and
spotted lanternfly which
are the latest slew of
invasives
climate change we know that that's going
to be a challenge i told you about it in
the north we're battling
not only frosts but hail so that's why
we use hail nets
in
the washington oregon area they're
battling drought
as opposed to this recent
a meme about uh in new york in our rains
but um
the drought and the heat are causing
sunburn that sunburn becomes a secondary
avenue
so how are we gonna breed for something
that can have such extreme
manifestations
and we are still pursuing this
so future opportunities
we have new flavors new markets hard
cider fresh cut healthy foods new
flavors textures
nutrients some of these will be club
varieties and others will be open to the
public at large
i want to thank you for your attention
and for being the next generation to be
following in our footsteps i have never
regretted my career choice a special
thanks to the apple industry cornell
colleagues my collaborators our field
staff kevin maloney and former students
and summer scholars
if there's time i'd be glad to open it
up for any questions
i thank you again for your attention and
for
your interest in plant breeding
you